update because I'm gonna go to the
cinema in a bit towards uh a new movie
open hyper this is not an advert
probably the movie looks good so uh
don't give me spoilers in the comments
although probably when I approach this
video I'll probably be in there in the
cinema but anyway let's talk about
Bitcoin what is bitcoin doing what
yesterday we were talking about the idea
that we had two weeks one to the upside
one to the downside and that we were
favoring the idea of the week to the
upside to get filled first okay
nevertheless
Bitcoin drop below the one or 50ma the
trading idea that I said yesterday was
Asia dumped London needed to hold and
then Bitcoin could pump all right but
the problem is that Bitcoin dropped okay
to fill this liquidity pool that's uh
in order to close this candle
this candle over here
are both the 150 May that's the purple
line you can see how it didn't it close
below the 150 main then the next candle
tested as resistance and then it drops
all right so that would be a nice short
scalp
okay now what can we expect today well
first of all
if we check the Bitcoin dominance
all right you're gonna notice
that it's not moving exactly the same as
Bitcoin okay yes we have this drop
okay then the 150 May held
and then it went up but Bitcoin is not
moving the same okay check out Bitcoin
this Bitcoin just fell below the 150 May
the Bitcoin dominance is something like
this
is not doing so what does that mean that
means that even if Bitcoin I mean it
seems quite stable to be honest
you mean it's holding
this Zone over here at least right so
it's quite stable but if you go and
check out coins what's going on with
altcoins check Solana
bleeding
checkmatic
believing let's continue check
um xrp
bleeding okay that's essentially because
the Bitcoin dominance is up now
let's have another look at the Bitcoin
dominance but the idea that I have here
to share with you is that as long as
Bitcoin doesn't Okay because in theory
the Bitcoin dominance it's highly
correlated with Bitcoin positive
correlation so it basically follows
Bitcoin so as long as Bitcoin doesn't
dump hard okay and the bit and the
Bitcoin dominance can hold
or continued pumping then what we can
expect for altcoins for example the case
of xrp is
maybe we can see a recovery you can see
here this liquidity pool so that's going
to line together with the 1 hour 50ma
okay if we see this pump over here fill
this well the trace is security pool
test the 50 meters resistance and
because the Bitcoin dominance is looking
quite strong
then you can Fable shorts all right
um that's that's maybe without coins at
the moment because I saw somebody asking
me on Twitter so that's what I think
about all coins at the moment okay you
have a video that I uploaded on Sunday
um that was quite interesting video
because it was
made for
spot buyers
um at the moment I'm a Trader I think
this this Market is more for a Trader
but in the next months I'm expecting
what I'm hoping that I can become also a
sport buyer if we see cheaper prices so
in love with the Uber marketing device
zones for 12 different all coins so go
and watch it guys if you are interested
in buying all coins for the bull market
okay but in the shorter term
something like that would be nice okay
the Bitcoin dominance is strong I wanna
favor lower prices and algories but for
that then I would like to see some kind
of retrace
maybe something like this
and then you can continue dropping okay
that's what I have in my mind now if you
go back to bitcoin something that it's
quite interesting is that if you notice
Bitcoin is holding here
okay but if we go to the Dollar to the
dollar Index
is pumping
go to the photos time frame I don't know
if you remember I think that was
Monday's video
if I remember correctly so that was uh
three days ago
I'm pretty sure
that we were around this Zone here and I
was saying that we were expecting the
dollar Index to continue pumping okay
it's just looking very strong and that
will be very bad for Bitcoin and the two
Targets that we marked was this
resistance over here
okay and also we marked this liquidity
pool
over here
right so what idea was the Bitcoin was
probably gonna come all the way to this
resistance okay and if
and if the dollar Index went above the
resistance test their support then we
could aim for this liquidity pool over
here a 102.60 I'm sure some of you will
remember that now you can see how the
dollar Index has gone above that line
tested a support a couple of times
and let's see because if it consolidates
over here we can maybe see one more
Spike retrace the liquidity pool okay or
maybe that is when you can see a little
retrace okay just to continue going
higher that's what I think for the
dollar Index now if you put this
together you have the dollar Index
pumping with that but that's bad for
Bitcoin because Bitcoin trades against
the dollar Index okay so in principle
Bitcoin should have been dumping
but it hasn't and now if you put that
together
with the idea
of
the SMP dumping
why is Bitcoin holding up why is Bitcoin
not falling yet
it's a sign of a strength
it could be anyway let's talk about this
setup okay
um we also talk about these setups we
were waiting for a deviation either at
this level over here or if we could
during push higher than on deviation at
this level now you can see how the SMP
is following a deviation already here
okay which basically is telling me that
if we lose this level over here
okay if you lose this level
that's a clear short to me to fill this
up all right now I didn't catch these
shorts yesterday because it happened
pretty quickly okay so what I'm waiting
here is
either I want to see a breakout below
this Zone okay or a breakout and then
consolidate below resistance that will
be ideal because that's usually a good
place for develop in a short okay and
then I'm gonna Target this Gap over here
between
4336 and
4 300 okay so that Gap is what I'm
looking at that's two hundred dollars
down all right so that's what I'm
expecting or if you see some kind of
retricia
well I test this so nice resistance
again then I'm gonna open another short
here with a stop loss at the highest all
right so that's what I'm looking at the
SMP but do you mean if we check
I don't know I clicked the one-hour time
frame look at SMP drop in go to the
other index one hour time frame the
dollar Index pumping go to bitcoin
it's holding guys
check this out
why is it holding and they said this
pump
the retrace holding so at the end of the
day what is still in the same Zone the
Bitcoin Bitcoin is not dumping why
I want to believe that that's a sign of
a strength but the cha is not looking
great neither okay
daily time frame
we close that candle hey what happened
to my range laws
foreign
now you can see how
that was a deviation
all right we close the daily the daily
candle below the rain slows and also
below the 50 amazing look how many
candlesia
below the 50ma in the daily time frame
but still it's not pushing price lower
why why if he keeps testing it a
resistance it doesn't drop lower
it's weird
okay
so I don't know what's up with Bitcoin
at the moment but
usually you see maybe a couple of hits
of the or two three four hits to the 50
amended daily time frame and then you
want to see a drop now it didn't happen
Okay you saw a drop that got a straight
away pumped up and now another retrace
at the end you're in the same Zone don't
have a liquidity below let's go back to
the four hour time frame you got
liquidity below a liquidity above both
both of them are gonna get filled but
it's quite difficult to figure out which
one is going to get filled first okay so
that's why we'll have to try to go in
lower time frame
and look for potential setups okay what
do we see here all right so what I see
here is a potential double information
check this out
okay now for me to open a long
today
what I would like to see is another
Spike here
support right and that's when you can
see another pump retrace boom towards
that week right so that's one setup but
for that of course I need to see this
second leg up
above the 50ma are retrace holding the
1500 time frame that's my long so that
will be around 29 230.
and then I'm gonna name for the week
above
946 not the 50 of the week that's the
first Target okay that's the setup that
I'm looking for today now
could Bitcoin go lower
yup but for that it needs to break
below this one over here okay so as long
as this song holds
what fun okay we can arrange even more
here or they can have a short squeeze
but the moment that we lose this Zone of
course you know if if you look below
this below this white line what do you
what do you see of course you see the
week that is not much more below okay so
not much to scalp here
because this I think like as long as we
are in this Zone here
so as long as we are in this one here
there isn't there is nothing to do I'm
not trading this small range of
200 all right but
the hyper liter traits in my opinion
would be a breakout below this Zone
towards the 50 of the week that's a
scalp all right or in the opposite
direction
uh double information
pump above the 150 May test it as
support that's my long and then you have
all the way here that's of course this
is more more tasty okay so what do I
prefer to see
I prefer to see the long set of scenario
because that is there is a lot more
distance okay
it's a two and a half percent trade
otherwise this is a small okay it's like
one percent trade so of course I prefer
to see the long setup
I'm only waiting
to react to bitcoin okay because I'm
telling you this week is particularly
difficult to read so if any of you have
been making money this week
congratulations okay it's quite been
quite difficult a week okay so what's
gonna happen next
um we'll see that's why I'm open-minded
to these two scenarios double
information or lose this Zone and go for
the week okay that's what I'm looking
for today now let's have a look at
hybrid Capital why don't have low
capital and if we check this liquidation
levels map
my conclusion is that there is more
liquidity below okay because if you
check the spikes at the right you see
more of a cluster of a spikes below
here is quite regular to the website but
it's true that you got two very
important levels do you have 29 500
and you also got here that one
thirty thousand eighty
that matches with the weak with the 50
of the week so
what I would like to see is
a spike up
to liquidate these high leverage Traders
at 29 500 and the week
at 30 000 and then a drop to go for this
liquidations okay I don't know if that's
going to happen that's my theory that
would be a week to week trade because
they would go for the week to the upside
first and then the week to the downside
but let's see what happens because at
the moment
it's not that clear okay so I'm leaning
towards that scenario I would really
like to see the long estimator playing
up because we have more distance of a
high probability trade which is really
good okay two and a half percent move
even if you use times four leverage
that's a 10 trade I mean that's that's
that would be great okay so that's what
I'm hoping to see double information gap
of the one or 50ma test their support
that's when I can open along then Target
the 50 of the of the week at 29 950.
if you want to go for these liquidations
at 30 080 and then from there maybe we
can see a drop
for the week below below I think it's
around 28 500 or so
so that's what I'm hoping to see that's
my Bitcoin analysis now I've seen that
some of you are asking for more altcoin
updates and so so
if so let me know please in the comments
what all coins you want me to do there
were some alkoons that I did in chart
for example xrp or
right so thank you so much for watching
and I'll see you soon